يبدو أن هناك نوعان مختلفان جديدان من الفيروس التاجي
يجعلان الفيروس أكثر سهولة في الانتشار ،
أحدهما تم تحديده لأول مرة في بريطانيا
تم اكتشافه بالفعل في الولايات المتحدة
بينما كان الأطباء قلقين من أنه ربما يكون قد
تحور بدرجة كافية للتهرب من
الحماية من اللقاح
، وتشير الأدلة الآن إلى أنه لم
يحدث ذلك
بعد.  في الشكل الثاني الجديد الذي شوهد لأول مرة
في جنوب إفريقيا ،
لا نريد أن تبدأ هذه السلالة في
الجري حول العالم
والتسبب في المزيد من الضرر ، يقول الدكتور ويليام
شافنر ، المسؤول السابق
في مركز السيطرة على الأمراض وأستاذ الأمراض المعدية في
جامعة فاندربيلت ، إنه
خلال الأسابيع القليلة المقبلة سيكون علماء الفيروسات
يدرس لمعرفة
مدى التطابق بين
هذا المتغير الجديد الذي تم تحديده لأول مرة في
جنوب إفريقيا
ويقول علماء اللقاحات لدينا إنه
يتعلق بمكان
التغييرات وكيف تؤثر على شكل
ووظيفة الفيروس ،
تستهدف جميع اللقاحات الحالية ما هو
يُعرف باسم البروتين الشائك ،
وهو الهيكل الذي يستخدمه الفيروس للوصول
إلى الخلايا التي
يهاجمها ولكن الطفرات التي تغير الطريقة
يمكن أن يساعد مظهر البروتين المرتفع هذا أيضًا في إخفائه من جهاز المناعة
مما يجعل الأجسام المضادة أقل فعالية إذا
لم
يكن هناك تطابق أو كان هناك انحراف كافٍ
، فسيتعين على الشركات المصنعة
العودة إلى العمل وإنشاء
لقاح آخر ونأمل أن
يغطي
كلا السلالتين من أجل الصحة  دقيقة أنا ماندي
جاثر